mark you added off-camera some
interesting tidbit about writers that
you were maybe surprised by
yeah sometimes um when i consult i find
that writer is not able to
upon a second read
execute those notes you know to make the
draft like
that much better or say well this part
wasn't working
and then it comes back and it's still
not working you know
and that's going to be a problem
in one's career if you can't execute
notes if you want to stay on
the idea is to stay on a project and not
get fired
uh not just sell a script you know
because it's gonna look bad if
if they take you off the project and um
yeah you might share credit but you'll
be known as like
you know you probably might not work
with that producer again because you
couldn't
execute the note you want to be the only
person on that
you know and it happens there are other
people that come in you know and
i've been on the other side where um
you know i was hired to rewrite a script
because the writer
was given many chances to do notes and
it just wasn't working
and so traditionally what they do i mean
they tend to say thank you very much but
we got to get somebody in here because
we're not going to trash the project
we're still going to make it but it's
not moving
where we need it to move you know so i
think that's
very important is to is to be able to
rewrite the script
and i think that comes from a place of
knowing structure knowing all the
elements that it takes to write a
screenplay
and many times like with the script i
had to
dismantle it to its essence and then
start again
you know like tear the house down but
leave the bathroom like okay but it's
still gonna be a house
and we still want it to be you know
mediterranean style
you know with eight bedrooms you like
got it but all this other stuff just not
working
and uh you know like like i was telling
you off camera about um
i just finished a polish um
and then i got notes this morning
and it's a polish so it's going through
and refining you know
you know stuff it's not like dismantling
you know it's switching things around
and it's maybe
hopefully three or four days of work
maybe five you know it's but it's not a
huge
you know you want to get to that point
if you do a polish then you're like oh
okay
most of it's settled but this has to be
you know raised in this scene you know
it's too subtle
you know things like that or uh in this
case
you know for reasons of production so
you go back through and you polish it
because
you know we want to cut down the number
of scenes we want to streamline this
aspect
things like that but you have to be able
to do that
on your own screenplay you know if you
want to stay
on the project you know executing notes
is extremely important
do you think that the reason
screenwriters or maybe new screenwriters
aren't
successful that is a resistance or
they don't understand it and they're not
trying to be difficult they just can't
see outside of their own i think i think
it's
more that than resistance uh could be a
little resistance because my words my
vision you know
and then you quickly learn like well it
it started to be your words and vision
and
now it's a rewrite you know and
hopefully a lot of it stays
but it's a collaborative art form and
you want to be a team player
to uh you know work once
you know like i say with my producer and
directors i work with you know
my once the script is now in the
development process
my job is to help get it made you know
and then
uh there are things that like i said
before you know you fight for
if you really believe in a change and
you'll talk
respectfully and maturely and say um
because you're talking
to other creative people who aren't out
to like
make a bad movie per se uh
sometimes it happens but you say well i
don't think
this will really work because of this
reason and as long as you defend it
you know with concrete evidence and then
you can convince
uh uh to keep it unchanged
but you also have to be open and more
times than not
thank goodness there's a producer to
guide it because
you know i some of my choices are like
oh i get why you're doing that okay
oh okay i see yeah actually actually
that's better
so it's not about who thought of what
because you're all in you're all in it
together
you know you put the ego aside and it
becomes like let's just
all work together to get the movie made
you know the best
version possible but back to your point
about i do think it's just um
lack of experience possibly where
someone has never received notes maybe
they never had a critique on their
script so they wouldn't know how to go
back in
and make those changes so that
rewriting is a good way uh
you know rewriting your bad scripts
rewriting your good ones is a good way
to gain that experience over
multiple drafts and you know multiple
screenplays to be like oh okay i know
what you're talking about
but then you'll get into a situation
where many producers are vague
you know what i mean and so there's no
school to go to where
a producer you know each like i said
before
each screenplay is a different
experience out of the gate different
producer different working experience
and one producer i worked with
i you know i tried to capture what he
was saying and i felt bad if i went oh
you know i don't quite understand
because then it makes me look like what
do you mean you don't understand
we hire oh and then i start feeling like
oh well
you know but it was all over bouncing
all over the map
big broad ideas that were changed on the
fly whoa um
did we go with this one or the other one
you know so you have to be available
ready for that
you know so um yeah there's all sorts of
situations but
um execution of the notes i i just
always have to say is extremely
important
yeah that was my next question that you
already went there but that was
what if it's not to to let the writer
off the hook but
sure the the notes that are being given
are not clear
and so then the writers fighting against
that or not
but just or not even fighting but just
trying to understand sometimes you'll
have maybe
the assistant you can go off to and you
know because you don't want to
look like you don't know what you're
doing you know and talk to them
and they'll be more than happy to be oh
you know i'm speaking on behalf of
whatever
um but i've been lucky that that um
people i've worked with are like razor
sharp you know like okay pitch 48
you know and i love those kind of notes
i don't like the broad stroke notes
because it leaves it up to you and then
you go this way with it and they're like
i wanted you to paint this way with a
twist you're like
okay so you know and then it gets bogged
down in development hell
and no one's ever gonna say that it's
their fault
you know they're gonna you're not
working you know it's not working
and you just oh okay all right
so of the sag screeners that you saw or
of some of the screeners or the films
that you saw
for 2019 what was the best script what
was the best writing
of all the films
well i saw um let's you know it's funny
because it's a script
you know i look at the scripts are
available so when you see the movie i
always look at the screenplay
and like jojo rabbit was literally
on the page and some scripts you read
because you don't know what draft you're
getting
if it's a production draft or it was the
final fine you know what i mean
and it was like oh that's because you
i always love to do that from years back
is to
see a movie you don't want to read the
script before because you'll ruin it
see the movie and then go back to see
like oh how would i have written that
scene and there's a particular scene i
won't say it in there
and i was like hmm and i looked and it
was exactly
you know we're not showing what we're
not showing and it was written on the
page and i was like wow that's
that's you know that's that's a good um
that's a good thing for writers to do as
well you know and
to read you have to read all the time
you know screenplays
and just i always say be careful of the
ones in awards season because
they're in a protected bubble so they're
not specs
so you can get away with a lot more
because you know it's it is in
development
you know i'm saying then you're spec i'm
saying with regards to format and things
like that
because then you know what you want
because we're all
we're on this protected bubble now it's
not a spec where i don't know you
i'm just i can only know you from what's
on this page
you know what i mean so i see some
writers want to try to emulate certain
styles
you know what i mean but i just say be
careful because those are either the
directors writing the script for the
screen
and can put a lot more things in the
script than
let's say maybe a spec would or should
what about dialogue of the 2019
contenders that you watched
who had the best dialogue and what what
was it
um parasite you know was talking about
don't be afraid of the inch and a half
you know subtitles
and i i've always loved foreign films so
i had no problem with subtitles
um but uh
yeah they all i mean once upon a time
the dialogue you know was
was really good i mean tarantino um
but i mean they're all there for a
reason these movies you know what i mean
there's there's some that didn't get
nominated and it was the snub and you
know but we all
we all should um champion a year of
great filmmaking
you know rather than oh who didn't get
the award or who wasn't nominated you
know we have such a
wide choice of stories and things now to
to
you know it's gotten so much better um
because everybody's a game you know the
game goes up you know what i mean
and you can see like oh that's not you
know
and who benefits but the filmmakers and
also the viewers
you know i really like bruce stearns
dialogue
and once upon a time in hollywood that
was really funny that was supposed to be
uh burt reynolds to play that part
ah yeah he passed away unfortunately oh
so yeah it's just interesting how that
would have made a different type of
character
you know i don't know because bruce dern
can kind of
uh disappear into a character
and bert was a great actor i think but
he's still burt reynolds
sure you know so how do you get around
for that in the last movie that he was
in i i saw was
the what was it called um
it was his last film before he passed
away it was great he played a
aging film star who goes to a film
festival
i think it's called the last movie star
okay possibly yeah
you